[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch katja stresow für den sport
schon genannt und wir haben unter
anderem diese themen für sie
unruhe in der cdu immer mehr fordern
einen neuanfang der ministerpräsident
von sachsen anhalt hält das schlechte
abschneiden seiner partei im osten für
wahlentscheidend
diskussion über masken pflicht in den
schulen ärzte verbände fordern sie
komplett aufzuheben virologen warnen
davor
keine lkw fahrer kein benzin in
großbritannien spitzt sich die lage an
den tankstellen zu jetzt sollen auf der
insel lebende deutsche aushelfen
eine woche nach der wahlniederlage
brodelt es immer heftiger in der cdu im
westen des landes aber auch im osten das
schlechte abschneiden der cdu in
ostdeutschland habe letztlich die wahl
entschieden sagt reiner haseloff
ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt
schauen wir uns die zahlen genauer vor
vier jahren hatte die cdu in
ostdeutschland noch die meisten
wahlkreise gewonnen doch jetzt
dominieren die spd und im südosten die
afd von den zweitstimmen bekommt die cdu
im osten nur rund 17 prozent bundesweit
sind es für die union
24,1 prozent wie das die basis auf sylt
auch auf dem landesparteitag in sachsen
anhalt zeigt andreas weise die stimmung
ist schlecht bei der sachsen
anhaltischen cdu ein mieses zweitstimmen
ergebnis bei der bundestagswahl sechs
von neun direktmandate verloren ein
scherbenhaufen für den ministerpräsident
haseloff auch das spitzenpersonal im
bund verantwortlich macht
so dass sich die kandidaten eine
wesentliche rolle mitgespielt haben
gerade in unübersichtlichen zeiten sind
programme das eine aber auf der anderen
seite eben auch der zugang zu bestimmten
personen
das muss jetzt sicherlich ausgewertet
werden von rücktrittsforderungen
gegenüber armin laschet hält haseloff
derzeit nichts noch soll ja mit fdp und
grünen im bund verhandelt werden gerade
mal vier monate ist es her da für die
cdu in sachsen-anhalt mit 37 prozent
einen furiosen sieg bei der landtagswahl
ein jetzt dieser absturz im bund der im
osten noch mal heftiger war weiterer
punkt hier in ostdeutschland ist dass
wir zu wenig oder gar keine ostdeutschen
themen hat das muss man einfach mal zur
kenntnis nehmen und am ende des tages
ist es auch so dass bei uns in
ostdeutschland unser spitzenkandidat
nicht überall angekommen ist kritik der
parteibasis hier auch am verhalten der
csu
niemand die alleinige schuld tragen wir
alle zusammen
auch
in bayern das ist nicht nur in sachsen
anhalt gerd zeigt dieser offene brief
des kreisverbandes altenburger land in
thüringen hier wird armin laschet offen
als falscher kandidat bezeichnet er war
als kandidat der falsche mann er war als
wahlkämpfer der falsche mann und er wäre
jetzt als kanzler der falsche mann die
union im osten irgendwo zwischen wut und
enttäuschung
das ergebnis der cdu im osten bei der
bundestagswahl kann getrost als
desaströs bezeichnet werden und der
hauptschuldige für viele hier ist armin
laschet jetzt werden rufe laut nach mehr
basis beteiligung wenn es darum geht
zukünftig
bundesvorsitzende und spitzenkandidaten
zu küren
nicht nur im osten drängen immer mehr
cdu politiker auf einen neuanfang
präsidiumsmitglied jens spahn forderte
in der welt am sonntag einen
sonderparteitag um die partei neu
aufzustellen
die nächste generation müsse stärker
sichtbar gemacht werden gemeinsam mit
anderen präsidiumsmitgliedern und mit
parteichef armin laschet traf er sich im
konrad-adenauer-haus um die
sondierungsgespräche morgen mit der fdp
vorzubereiten
ganz anders die stimmung bei den grünen
bei ihrem kleinen parteitag in berlin
zeigten sie sich entschlossen zu
regieren auch wenn es anstrengend und
kompliziert werde die grünen müssten
offen in die anstehenden gespräche gehen
sagte parteichefin baerbock die weiteren
sondierungen wird ein zehnköpfiges team
übernehmen über einen möglichen
koalitionsvertrag und die personelle
aufstellung sollen am schluss die rund
120.000 mitglieder abstimmen
extrem frustrierend war der wahlsonntag
auch für die linke wenn nicht gregor
gysi und zwei andere direktmandate
ergattert hätten dann wäre die partei
aus dem bundestag geflogen heute berät
der vorstand über konsequenzen aus
berlin andreas künast
s8 und kracht in der linken während die
parteiführung zu geschlossenheit aufruft
und zur geduld werden fast täglich
offene briefe bekannt offene drohungen
offener krach schon vor beginn der
vorstandsklausur gibt ein teil der
partei der parteispitze die schuld und
vor allem dem ziel die linke in die
regierung zu führen
rot-rot-grün über alles oder rot grün
rot über alles auch ganz ohne inhalte
brauchen wir nicht hauptsache wir sind
in der
regierungsbeteiligung 30 abgeordnete
müssen nach dem wahldesaster ihre büros
räumen die wut ist groß in allen lagern
im vorstand geht es hoch her
fraktionschef bartsch wird vorgeworfen
ein macht- und stillhalte bündnis mit
wagenknecht geschmiedet zu haben er wird
die sitzung schon am mittag verlassen so
deutlich und so ehrlich heißt es habe
sich dieser vorstand noch nie
ausgesprochen
wir haben flächendeckend
und massiv verloren und natürlich ist es
auch so dass man jetzt sechs tage nach
dieser wahl keine fertigen antworten hat
besonders umstritten sahra wagenknecht
ein teil der partei will sie loswerden
ein teil der fraktion will dass sie
sichtbarer wird natürlich sind sarah und
auch ich schon personen in der partei
die eine bestimmte rolle spielen und das
müssen die anderen lernen zu nutzen also
nicht immer davon ausgeht vielleicht wie
macht man sie eher unsichtbar sondern
umgekehrt es geht um die alten konflikte
der linken und um neue es geht mal
wieder um alles
zum thema corona müssen schüler und
schülerinnen weiter masken im unterricht
ragen nein sagen ärzteverbände und
fordern die masken pflicht aufzuheben
virologen dagegen warnen vor steigenden
infektionszahlen in bremen thüringen
sachsen anhalt mecklenburg vorpommern
und im saarland müssen im unterricht
grundsätzlich keine masken mehr getragen
werden jetzt in bayern und berlin nach
ab nächster woche ist auch dort die
masken pflicht im unterricht abgeschafft
thomas garcia
für viele und jugendliche gilt über
viele stunden pauker mit maske party
machen ohne maske dürfen ältere dagegen
oft ungerecht für mit der ärztepräsident
das sei zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wo wir in
der gastronomie im theater im kino auch
im büro am platz als erwachsene keine
masken mehr tragen ist unangemessen und
nicht angebracht und die kinder nicht
mehr zumutbar und aus diesem grunde
plädiere ich dafür dass masken tragen
während des unterrichts am platz für die
schüler aufheben denn kinder seien eben
keine pandemie treiber erkrankungen bei
ihnen seltener und weniger schwer die
hospitalisierung rate beträgt bei den
fünf bis 14 jährigen aktuell 0,48 der
niedrigste wert von allen altersstufen
umgekehrt ist es aber den infektionen
die sieben tage incidents mit
152,5 die höchste aller altersstufen
deshalb sagt der lehrer verband
eigentlich hoffen natürlich
[Musik]
die virologen warnen vor einer großen
vierten welle die sich verschärfen wird
und da jetzt sozusagen die meisten
pflicht abzuschaffen halten wir für
voreilig besser vorsichtig sein sagt
virologin brinkmann und zu den
lockerungen an schulen bei der hohen
anzahl an nicht geimpften und hierzu
zählen die kinder halte ich diese
entscheidung für verfrüht und ehrlich
gesagt auch für ziemlich dumm die
debatte leicht erhitzt der herbst ist da
und mit ihnen die ungewissheit wie es
weitergeht in der pandemie
wenn sie noch mehr zum masken pflicht an
schulen wissen wollen auf unserer zdf
heute app finden sie unterschiedliche
meinungen dazu etwa warum kinderärzte
gegen eine masken pflicht im unterricht
sind
schauen wir in die usa in texas gilt
seit einem monat ein radikales
abtreibungsverbot nicht nur die
regierung hält das für verfassungswidrig
frauenrechtsorganisationen haben zu
protesten aufgerufen in mehr als 600
städten wollen sie bis zu
250.000 menschen auf die straße bringen
gegen das landesweit strengste
abtreibungsgesetz
allein in washington werden 40.000 vor
dem supreme court erwartet dem höchsten
gericht benjamin daniel ist für uns vor
ort was wollen die menschen mit ihrem
protest erreichen
sie wollen erreichen dass das recht auf
abtreibung in den usa bestehen bleibt
auslöser war dass sehr viel diskutierte
abtreibungsgesetz in texas das verbietet
die abtreibungen
sobald man die ersten herzschläge gehört
und das ist in der regel ja so etwa nach
der sechsten woche der fall und das
macht es im prinzip unmöglich eine
legale abtreibung durchzuführen die
marschroute hier der demonstrantinnen
und demonstranten die führt hier vom
freedom plaza in washington zum supreme
court zum obersten gericht das ist
natürlich kein zufall denn dort werden
sich die richterinnen und richter ab
montag unter anderem mit diesem thema
befassen und nicht wenige hier
befürchten dass es sein könnte dass das
verfassungsmäßig gegebene recht auf
abtreibung in den usa irgendwann
vielleicht gekippt wird und dagegen
wollen sie sich heute stark machen live
aus washington benjamin daniel vielen
dank
premiere im arabischen emirat katar dort
gab es erstmals eine landesweite wahl
abgestimmt wurde über 30 mitglieder
einer sogenannten beratenden versammlung
der wüstenstaat am persischen golf ist
eine absolute monarchie der emir
entscheidet alles allein politische
parteien sind verboten
im parlament gibt es nicht von den rund
drei millionen einwohnern ist nur eine
kleine minderheit
wahlberechtigt
die verzweiflung ist groß in england
sprit ist seit acht tagen mangelware an
den tankstellen weil es nach dem wechsel
zu wenig lkw fahrer gibt die regierung
ist so unter druck dass sie nun eine
brief kampagne startete adressiert auch
an deutsche in großbritannien die einen
alten führerschein besitzen was ist
damit auf sich hat andreas stamm
kein durchkommen eine tankstelle in
london nachdem bekannt wird hier gibt es
noch sprit mancherorts hat sich die lage
stabilisiert doch von allein wie die
regierung hoffte nach der ersten welle
von panikkäufen lösen sich die schlangen
nicht auf das militär bislang auf
standby wird nun aus rücken
200 militärpfarrer werden es im laufe
der woche seien die erste hälfte
trainiert das wochenende durch und kann
dann montag eingesetzt werden
5000 trucker aus der eu sollen zudem
sofort visa erhalten ursprünglich für
drei nun für sechs monate an den kurz
visa gibt es aber bislang kaum interesse
100.000 fahrer fehlen so die
transportunternehmer vor allem wegen des
brh exit der eu vertrieben habe die
verzweiflung groß das zeigt dieser brief
gerichtet unter anderem an deutsche mit
älteren autoführerschein die damit auch
einen 7,5 tonner fahren dürfen und nun
von der regierung gebeten werden als
lkw-fahrer anzuheuern was an einer
deutschen samstag schule in london für
erheiterung sorgt die von unseren
lehrerin das tatsächlich den brief
gekriegt haben mit dem angebot und was
soll ich denn jetzt noch
lastwagenfahrerin werden also ich finde
damit macht man sich auch regierung eher
lächerlich kann ich meinen job aufgeben
um lkw zu fahren ich kann das zwar
machen mit dem führerschein aber ich
habe noch nie in meinem leben lkw
gesessen und erst recht nicht durch die
straßen londons die maßnahmen seien ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein so die
wirtschaft in der arbeitsreichsten zeit
des jahres vor weihnachten seien durch
den fahrermangel weitere
versorgungsengpässe garantiert nicht nur
an zapfsäulen
der internationale karlspreis in aachen
gilt als einer der renommiertesten und
wichtigsten auszeichnungen europas
winston churchill hat ihn bekommen auch
angela merkel heute wurde damit ein mann
geehrt der als besondere brückenbauer
zwischen ost und west gilt der
rumänische präsident klaus johannes wolf
christian ullrich hat mir ein
herausragender streiter für die
europäischen werte so die würdigung für
rumäniens präsidenten klaus johannes der
heute in seiner rede ein europa der
gleichen geschwindigkeit beschwor und
mehr mittel für bildung forderte als
grundstein europäischer demokratie die
union ist heute mehr denn je auf einheit
solidarität und zusammenhalt
angewiesen der politische aufstieg des
siebenbürger sachsen begann in sibiu als
bürgermeister sanierte er in enormen
tempo die infrastruktur lockte hunderte
deutsche unternehmen an machte sie bio
zur europäischen kulturhauptstadt und
rückte die stadt so in den fokus europas
die bio hat sich in eine attraktive
lebenswerte stadt entwickelt tausende
gäste besuchen uns jedes jahr das ist
eine außerordentliche leistung die wir
ihm verdammt
johannes stand dabei für
rechtsstaatliches handeln
auftragsvergabe ohne klingel und das in
einem land in dem die korruption von der
provinz bis in höchste regierungsämter
erreicht dieser johannes effekt wie man
den nennt der hat natürlich gesteuerten
guten sinne dass das recht eingehalten
wird das tat er denn das kolleg
gearbeitet wird und dass alle die
gleiche chance haben genau das dankte
ihm die große mehrheit der rumänen und
wählte ihn zweimal zum präsidenten des
landes weil er für die seele des
europäischen einigungsprozesses
unersetzlich sei erhielt er heute den
aachener karlspreis ein leuchtturm in
südosteuropa wo unredlichkeit und
korruption in der politischen elite weit
verbreitet sind
und jetzt der sport jubel bei
deutschlands tischtennis spielerinnen
sie stehen im em-finale das tun sie und
das ist umso überraschender und
beeindruckender weil die deutschen
frauen eigentlich nicht in topbesetzung
bei der mannschafts em in rumänien am
start sind aber sie haben trotzdem top
abgeliefert und im halbfinale portugal
mit 3 zu 1 gesiegt ein umjubelter erfolg
bei der em 2009 10 hatten die deutschen
frauen noch in bestbesetzung gegen
portugal verloren jetzt die revanche
wollen dank nina mittel haben die mit
zwei siegen zum matchwinner wurde
chantal mantz hat er für die deutsche 2
2 1-führung gesorgt als nina mittel
haben in ihrem zweiten einzel auf
portugals spitzenspielerin juhu traf den
ersten satz verlor sie kämpfte sich aber
zurück und zeigte ihr bestes tischtennis
zuletzt hatten sich die beiden im finale
des europäischen top 16 turniers
gegenüber gestanden da gewann die 24
jährige deutsche und diesen sieg konnte
sie wiederholen drei zu eins das
endergebnis zu gunsten des deutschen
teams morgen im finale geht es gegen
top-favorit rumänien
jetzt zur fußball bundesliga und den
bisher 18 toren diese siebten spieltages
jede ergebnisse dortmund bleibt zu hause
eine macht besiegt augsburg 2 1 freiburg
weiter ohne niederlage gewinnt 2 zu 1
bei hertha bsc wolfsburg unterliegt
gladbach 13 stuttgart souverän gegen
hoffenheim 3 zu 1 am abend empfängt
leipzig bochum das spiel dann
ausführlich im aktuellen sportstudio und
bereits gestern köln führt drei zu eins
in der tabelle sind dortmund und
freiburg heute bis auf einen punkt an
die bayern vorgerückt die spielen morgen
genau wie leverkusen die dann auf zwei
hochklettern können dann kommt wolfsburg
köln und mainz gladbach hat einen
passablen sprung gemacht von elf auf
acht die zweite hälfte hoffenheim vor
stuttgart und leipzig ganz unten hoffen
bielefeld und bochum es endlich aus dem
keller zu schaffen führt weiter letzter
von 23 uhr an ist stuttgarts
sportdirektor sven misslingt zu gast im
aktuellen sportstudio und klärt auf über
die momentane leicht kriselnde situation
in der führungsebene beim vfb jetzt ins
wasser die kurzbahn-saison der schwimmer
hat mit dem weltcup in berlin begonnen
und florian wellbrock gewann über die
1500 meter erst auf den letzten metern
konnte er sich vom großen markt teamchef
absetzen dritter wurde sven schwarz aus
hannover
die britin lucy dann hat die vom
frühjahr in den herbst verlegt premiere
des frauen rennens beim rad klassiker
paris roubaix gewonnen die letzten 80
der insgesamt 116 km davon auch über das
berüchtigte
kopfsteinpflaster vor die britin
souverän allein die deutsche lisa
brennauer wurde vierter morgen sind dann
die männer dran nils polit ist favorit
muss man auch mögen mit dem kopf
schneller
wichtiger hinweis von ostend harry in
den nächsten stunden wird es von westen
her stürmisch mehr dazu gleich beim
wetter mit ihm das heute journal mit
marietta slomka um viertel vor elf danke
für ihr interesse wir wünschen ihnen
noch einen unbeschwerten samstag abend
bis morgen wenn es immer so
[Musik]
schönen abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter die großwetterlage wird
derzeit von zwei riesigen druck gebilden
bestimmt einmal dieses sehr umfangreiche
hoch über russland und das tiefe über
westeuropa und das schickt uns einige
run tiefs und dieses hier wird für sturm
sorgen aus dem süden und dessen
kaltfront reicht von den von
skandinavien über frankreich bis raus
auf den atlantik also ziemlich lang
diese kaltfront oder auf der vorderseite
wird warme luft heran gesagt so viel zur
großwetterlage in der nacht also in den
nächsten stunden vor allem wird es
windig von süden her müssen wir mit
sturmböen rechnen und es kommt regen auf
ansonsten ist es trocken und die
temperaturen sinken auf 7 grad an den
alpen und 17 grad im westen das ist die
tiefste temperatur der kommenden nacht
dort und morgen dann schmeckt die
kaltfront erst einmal in den westen viel
ring dabei weiterhin sturmböen zum
nachmittag dann in den südwesten
ansonsten bleibt es trocken bei höchsten
temperaturen bis 26 grad an den alpen
herrscht föhnsturm kühler an der nordsee
mit 17 grad und die nächsten tage am
montag geht der regen dann weiter im
osten bis 20 grad ja und dann geht es
wechselhaft weiter und damit ein schöner
abend